on analyse tout ça avec les économistes
de jean pierre aubry et serge coulombe
dans soir à tous les deux bonsoir
bonsoir à la première femme à occuper ce
poste depuis la fondation du canada
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
nomination je vais commencer avec vous
monsieur coulombe est ce que c'est le
bon choix c'est la meilleure candidate
a mon avis oui c'est la meilleure
candidate
le pôle d'expérience que certains
auraient aimé d des entreprises
mais alors montré beaucoup de leadership
et d'une grande capacité intellectuelle
et une grande capacité économique dans
sa carrière jusqu'à maintenant
donc moi je la verrai même
éventuellement comme pour mes amis
n'est-ce donc ces personnes que
clairement l'envergure du poste et
espérons qu'elle fera bien parce que la
situation présentement est extrêmement
difficile
wen n'a pas de formation en économie en
tant que tel vous le mentionnez pas
d'expérience dans le milieu des affaires
non plus comme comme d'autres candidats
compenser potentiel comme marc année par
exemple ce qui est un problème monsieur
aubry je ne pense pas je pense qu'on a
besoin de quelqu'un de très intelligent
quelqu'un qui traîne qui va travailler
très fort quelqu'un qui est capable de
travailler en équipe
ils vont à des conseillers autour d'elle
et je pense qu'elle est très capable de
trouver d'excellents conseillers de les
écouter
je pense qu'elle a une grande capacité d
analyse
oui elle en a fait la preuve ça entre
autres avec les négociations pour le
renouvellement de l'accord de
libre-échange bon le ce qui est clair
c'est ce qu'affirme adam freeland c'est
un défi colossal permettre à l'économie
canadienne de rebondir après une crise
historique
mais trouver l'équilibré aussi entre
mesures de relance et gestion des
dépenses et ça devrait quoi ces
priorités monsieur coulon oui à venir
jusqu'à maintenant le l'emphase du
parlement fédéral était surtout sur m
d'économies canadienne dans un coma
profond
en donnant des centaines de milliards de
da
aux ménages et aux entreprises et sans
parler de deux programmes de relance
alors dans la dernière mise à jour de
monsieur morneau en juillet il n'y avait
pas une seule fois le mot relance qui
était prononcé donc maintenant on doit
un peu changer de disque
c'est un peu plus la ministre des
finances qui doit prendre l'initiative
de destinés à des programmes qui sont
qui sont très forts au niveau de
l'analyse bénéfices coûts et parce que
bon il est clair que d'immenses dépenses
qui ont été faites jusqu'à maintenant le
peuvent continuer éternellement
ce sont des dépenses qui ont profité du
financement de la banque du canada qui a
acheté pour plus de 220 milliards de
dollars de la dette du gouvernement
fédéral depuis le début de la crise qui
est la première fois de l'histoire et
mais il semblerait que la france que la
fontaine pourrait se tarir
il n'y a pas eu dachau au cours des cinq
dernières semaines donc il faut penser à
revenir à une analyse basée sur
l'économique plutôt que sur
l'empressement à venir jusqu'à
maintenant c'est on était pressé
donc ça fait six mois qu'on est pressé
mais dans ces tas de construire oui on
passe du mode urgence au mode plus
planifier une stratégie
par contre quand vous parliez des
dépenses on croit comprendre qu'une des
raisons du départ de monsieur mono et
aubry ce serait que il agitait des
drapeaux rouge et l'était peut-être
offrait à continuer à dépenser sans
compter est-ce que justin trudeau aurait
choisi christophe willem justement parce
qu'est ce que prépare elle à délier
encore les cordons de la bourse est ce
que ça vous inquiète sa non ça
m'inquiète pas je pense que comme je
mentionnais tantôt elle est capable
d'analyser une solution de penser à long
terme
elle est capable d'acier de trouver les
meilleures façons avec beaucoup de gens
auto d'autres gouvernements se fait que
je pense que le travail qu'elle va faire
avant aider à trouver les meilleures
solutions mais il est tel point risque
vous évoquez le monsieur coulombe le
fait de compte peut plus continuer de
dépenser sans compter le gouffre il est
déjà profond on a parlé de 343 milliards
de déficit la dette qui dépasse les 1000
milliards de dollars est ce que les
agences de notation par exemple
pourraient sans malice que c'est un
risque pour le coût d'emprunt du
cannabis oui et c'est ignorer risque dix
ans que je cours moins d'importance aux
agences de notation depuis le travail
horrible qu'ils ont fait avec la crise
2008 2009 mais effectivement quand je
vous lise y avait beaucoup à
l'entraînement mais il faut noter qu'il
n'y a pas eu de budget depuis le mois de
mars 2019
alors moi qu'est ce que je trouve qu'ils
manquent dans l'analyse maintenant
d'être dans la proche budget entre
l'amant fédéral depuis le début de la
crise et enjoint de check and balance
pour employer un mot anglais à savoir
qu' on doit expliquer qu'est ce qu'on
fait et on doit de faire voter dans un
budget et puis a présentement il ya des
décisions qui ont été prises qui
implique des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliards et des centaines de milliards
de dollars qui enquiquine ont été prises
avec un petit vote en catimini en
rapidité
nous devons revenir à un processus
budgétaire ou les actions du
gouvernement sont basées sur une scène
analyse économique en ayant pour but le
bien-être des canadiens et pas
uniquement la question de la santé
publique il faut avoir une approche
beaucoup plus large et là dessus
en somme adam freeland qui ont montré au
cours de sa carrière qu'elle est capable
de penser large on a besoin de quelqu'un
qui pense large et qui doit même de
check and balance face à la volonté de
dépenser que monsieur trudeau a démontré
avec le npd d'ailleurs etc sont un peu
de connivence ensemble présentement à aa
à savoir ce qu'ils agissent comme comme
un gouvernement vraiment très à gauche
dans la dépense attente elle est une fin
en soi c'est sûr que les dépenses ont
été critiqués et monsieur aubrée je vous
entendre là dessus il ya des gens qui
ont dit que c'était bar ouvert à ottawa
est ce que le gouvernement la nouvelle
ministre vont entendre les critiques
triptyque compte innovatrice en trop qui
demandent un meilleur contrôle de la
dette et des dépenses ce sera une de ses
priorités dans le budget y croyez sur
mer parce que comme on le mentionnait
tantôt c'est pas juste importantes
dépensées il faut bien dépenser
vous parliez un peu d'incertitude les
agences de notation et chuter alors la
meilleure façon de réagir c'est de bien
dépenser et de favoriser une saine
reprise juste de penser puis d'aller de
jour en jour le bar ouvert c'est très
mauvais sur le long terme et avant même
le budget monsieur aubry est ce qui ne
devrait pas intervenir mme adam freeland
sur des programmes existants qui sont
pas parfaits est ce qu'elle peut et
qu'est-ce qu'elle devrait changer
c'était important si on note que dans
certains programmes
il ya certains points qui maintenant
sont rendus au lieu d productive selon
du contre-productif
il faut également vous chantez à la pcu
là monsieur aubry ce soir et il faut
absolument bouger parce que les dépenses
sont énormes et difficiles sont
importants et c'est un d'incitation à
faire attention à tourner comme disait
tantôt monsieur couderc d'aller vers la
relance et de bien justifiée et bien
expliquer au public
quand on parle de bar ouvert des unes
des implications de jazz c'est qu'on a
pas expliqué correctement au public que
ça a été pensé bien jugé bien analyser
ce qu'il faut que ça change
je pense est un des grands défauts ce
monsieur morneau qui lançait des idées
et qui avait pas de suivi ouais ben
parlons pas de monsieur morneau
justement bon est ce que vous y croyez à
ses explications concernant fondée par
le fait qu'il souhaitait une continuité
avoir quelqu'un en poste pour toute la
reprise économique si vous voulez pas un
mot sur le scandale unies monsieur
coulombe vous en pensez quoi
alors ce ne sont que des mots madame
st-arnaud disons qu'il devait il se
devait de dire quelque chose et moi ce
que je retiens c'est que le capitaine
délaisse le navire en plein milieu de la
pire tourmente des depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale
donc les gens ont raison d'être inquiets
et je ne veux pas revenir sur le
scandale de la de la witch meeting de
toronto
on en a abondamment parlé et ils
méritaient amplement de se faire montrer
la porte
mais disons que les les membres
d'équipage et des passagers en raison
d'être inquiet et madame freelance à 60
heures justement de ramener le ministère
des finances donc l'équipage a travaillé
pour le bien commun et à faire en sorte
que les passagers qui sont les marchés
et les canadiens reprennent confiance
dans le ministère des finances a été
calme le ministre des finances arrive un
matin et avoir une comparution devant un
comité de la chambre des communes sur le
lien avec le wit charité et qui dit ah
j'ai fait un chèque de 41000 dollar ce
matin
c'est évidemment tout faire pour faire
perdre confiance en nos ministres des
finances auront le pouvoir de ministre
des finances est entre autre basée sur
la confiance que les gens en deux dans
ses actions
d'ailleurs monsieur aubrée vous vous
êtes un peu critique de la façon dont
j'ai ré monsieur morneau les financent
les programmes et les prix n'étaient pas
toujours dans le départ est selon vous
absolument pas on lance l'idée ça a été
souvent fait assez rapidement après ça
on en parle très peu de budget un budget
on voit pas l'idée initiale comment elle
a évolué le meilleur exemple c'est le
programme 287 milliards de départs des
feux
sur 12 1 qui était un programme énorme
sur lequel le gouvernement comptait pour
accroître le potentiel de l'économie
après un ou deux budget aux mises à jour
après ça on n'entend pas parler on sait
pas où on en était en avance en arrière
et ça se fait pas avec des chiffres
comme ça alors c'est pas de bénéfice à
faire lors bon alors là clairement on a
tourné la page et la prorogation
suspension des travaux il y aura 10
coûteront budget en octobre
on sait vous même que le gouvernement
pourrait tomber ce qu'est ce que ça
pourrait vouloir dire est en élection à
l'automne un possible deuxième vague ça
vous dit quoi comme scénario de ce
coulombe
oui pour que le gouvernement entend mais
devrait perdre l'accord du npd qui lui
n'a aucun intérêt à faire tomber le
gouvernement
le npd n'ont jamais vu de toute son
histoire un gouvernement
arrivé avec un agenda autant social
démocrate
donc il est aussi bien de participer le
plus longtemps qu'il peut à l'exercice
de danse que libéraux et néo-démocrates
ont trouvé pour s'entendre à ottawa donc
ça prend juste le npd pour le garder vos
pouvoirs
donc c'est ça tout le danger avec la
politique budgétaire c'est que le
gouvernement peut aisément en rester au
pouvoir
en gardant un
un agen d'autres qui pourrait être perçu
comme étant très très très à gauche et
donc moi je suis également et qui est de
ce côté là donc pas juste les membres
d'équipage et puis les passagers qui
sont inquiets il ya aussi des
observateurs
oui qu'est-ce que vous inquiète un
endettement qui ne serait pas maîtrisé
trop de dépenses non moi j'ai
l'impression que tu vas manger libéralo
profiter de la crise pour pouvoir faire
baisser le niveau démocratique du canada
en contournant le parlement et en se
basant sur ses origines allemandes et
les intérêts d'un d'une petite
proportion des canadiens qui sont
extrêmement bien servi présentement et
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on se retrouve
dans une situation qui fait bien les
affaires des libéraux présentement
bon en tout cas on verra si les choses
semblent avec une en partie une nouvelle
équipe de nouvelles orientations qu'on
attend de la part du gouvernement selon
vous monsieur oublié le mot de la fin ce
serait quoi le plus grand défi du
gouvernement et de sa nouvelle équipe
c'est encore de reprendre le terrain
avec des bonnes décisions des programmes
pour aider la reprise
il faut réduire le programme de support
et transférer cet effort l'eau vers la
reprise et avoir des nerfs et des
comptes rendus et ont suivi de la
situation
monsieur coulombe en 15 secondes si vous
étiez ministre des finances ce que ce
soir là vous vous acharnez à quels
dossiers que je pense qu'il faut
absolument changer rapidement les
mesures proposées récemment pour la
subvention salariale qui qui qui qui
semble devenir pas mon genre de
plumpy'nut dans lequel les entreprises
rogers vont pouvoir se servir je me
demande qui a eu l'idée de décider à ces
changements mais il faut faire
clairement un pas en arrière
alors on entend une recommandation à
tous les deux merci beaucoup d'avoir été
là on se prend une bonne soirée